the attack on Manchester last night the
terrorist outrage is utterly
heartbreaking it's been made all the
more clear to me this morning as I spoke
to my kids all of whom each had a friend
or more at the gig last night in
Manchester and we know that every
terrorist attack on our country is the
TUC on every single one of us but this
is of a different order this was a
terrorist attack deliberately targeted
at children having the time of their
lives
it was cowardly it was deliberate it is
beyond wicked and that is why it's right
that we should determine that justice
must be done and we continue to stand up
to those who wish to harm our society to
take away life and to take away our
liberty and our freedom but beyond that
it's so important to do we recognize
that last night and throughout this day
we see in Manchester and Britain at
their absolute best our emergency
services whilst people were running away
stricken from this outrage people
putting themselves in harm's way running
towards it to help those who are injured
and worse and we say also the people of
Manchester opening their homes or in
their cars open their shops and their
businesses church halls and everything
else to warmly embrace and get alongside
those people who are affected there is
so much that this day we can be proud of
in Manchester's response to all of this
and in our emergency services to whom we
are immensely grateful and just as we
should be determined that justice must
be done we should also remember what it
is that the terrorists want they want us
to be scared it wants to give up our
Liberty in order to give up our freedom
they want us to give up our way of life
because they hate all of those things
and therefore today we should be
determined standing shoulder to shoulder
with the people of Manchester with one
another across the country but we will
not give in to the terrorists we will
continue our way of life we will do so
with determination
you said that your children knew people
at the concert can I ask you how you
explained and talked about the attack
with your children and whether you know
that how they are today well the
conversation I had with them which was
over breakfast this morning we knew very
little about where those friends were we
know a little bit more now things are
being revealed as we speak and I think
it's appropriate for me to go into any
more details about those people's
whereabouts but clearly has a massive
impact upon them and that is something
that is going to be the case around
every breakfast table around every home
in this country as parents explain to
their children how people can do
something so despicable to other
children and it is a reminder how
important it is that we stand together
as a community that we care for another
way are decent to one another and we
stand utterly resolute and defiant
against the time terrorists who would
seek to take our lives and take away our
Liberty this is a moment where we stand
up for one another and to the terrorists
and determined that our way of life will
not change can I just ask what you think
the appropriate time period should be
for general election campaigning to be
suspended well all the parties and
ourselves labor the Conservatives have
been discussions and we're absolutely of
the view that our campaigning our
national campaigns have been suspended
today what happens in the future that's
that's something to be discussed but I
think today is not a day for us to be
considering that and the general
election campaign it all seems pretty
small in comparison with the unspeakable
outrage that took place in Manchester
the wickedness those children were
victims of and the importance for us to
have our our thoughts constantly with
those who are grieving and who were
affected directly and indeed in my case
you know constantly holding those people
in my prayers I think today is not a day
for politicking